we are live for the next couple of hours
oh we got him coming up super bowl fifty
four here he comes there he is i'm
moving over
by storm as a rookie this year the walk
on gardner mitchu nice to see you we'll
get him a seat and off we go
right man live tv you never know what's
going to happen you never know who's
going to show up we're going to put you
over there on the edge
oh and he's got a chain too that we're
going to steal from him before he leaves
doesn't need that the rest of the day
all right sixth round pick out a
washington state a heisman finalist in
2018 and gardner i got to tell you the
story week one we gather in the nbc
viewing room for the games
season starting
and uh
somebody called out hey who's the
jaguars backup quarterback silence
and so he said gardner minshew it's like
oh yeah gardner-mitchum washington state
he's on their roster and then within 20
minutes later you're in the game yeah
you're in the game right hey
yeah if things happen fast in the nfl
yeah no doubt so i like honestly i just
moved into my apartment with two
roommates uh that thursday
uh before that game like i didn't know
if i was making the team even like and
then you know 12 plays in the year i'm
playing uh it's crazy crazy how god
works but man i was you know extremely
excited for that starting quarterback in
the nfl got roommates it doesn't sound
right it doesn't sound right i mean what
was the year you took the league by
storm for a period of time and rightly
so man you were fun to watch i mean you
bring some charisma and everything to
the jacksonville jaguars what like what
was some of the weirdest moments for the
year because it seems like a lot of
people were coming to get interviews and
things like that yeah um you know i
think one of the biggest things is i
kind of got like a small taste of that
at washington state like you know is
that that kind of crazy just on a
smaller scale yeah so i think i was
prepared pretty well for it and um you
know i think jacksonville is definitely
my type of people you know so they are
it is a match made in heaven yeah it
definitely is i'm digging the look again
today i mean you're always styling you
know i do i do what i can where'd you
get this from where did you come up with
your style i mean where did it come from
i got to tell you everything i wear yeah
is like stuff i've gotten for free
somehow like i've i've been bought
clothes since like high school
i'm not embarrassed to say that
you are a little your face just turned
red a little yeah so i mean oops sorry
that's the way to do it though man free
clothes is the way to go
you just put it in the closet you pull
it out you put on and then by the time
it wears out you get more free stuff
right it's it's just it's easy easy
system what what have you learned
throughout the course of your rookie
season that you wish you'd known the
moment you walked out onto the field in
that game against the chiefs week one
yeah um i think the biggest thing just
on the field was like the speed like not
necessarily in the back end but up front
like guys get on you quick obviously
strip that ball like they can touch you
from like over here you know so just
that ball security you know kind of
understanding that and getting that
awareness but i think by the end of the
year did a better job but uh just kind
of understanding that the hardest thing
to get used to because you could play
games in the pac-12 where you might not
play one nfl defense alignment and all
of a sudden you get in an nfl game and
you're like whoa these are all big and
fast i had the same adjustment i think
it was the hardest thing absolutely i
want to like you know how you know a lot
of people look at guys like you that
come from the you know the red raider
texas tech type offense and they think
you're not prepared for the nfl
sometimes because that's not life in the
nfl like tell us like how did mike leach
prepare you for the nfl yeah so i think
it you know every offense in college
prepares you in different ways for the
nfl yeah i think in the air raid
you the playbook is much smaller right
but you have to be able to access
everything at the line of scrimmage all
the checks are on you right you're
always like finding fronts looking in
the back end right trying to find
advantages so it puts you in a different
mindset
um whereas you know a lot of guys are
going up to line of scrimmage said
look at the coach coach what do i do
should i do i run the play right so okay
i'll run the play yeah right and it's
not like that so i think every offense
kind of prepares you differently yeah
why do you think it is the folks in
jacksonville have taken to you the way
they have
yeah um i think i got like just the
right amount of like white trashiness to
me um you know so i think you know i
think i found my people that's why they
liked me in tampa too
so right honestly i like i love
jacksonville uh love the people there
it's been a blast living there um you
know and i think it's only going to get
better you know well are you are your
jorts
free or are those homemade no those were
goodwill homemade so that's a a lot
that's that's the last close-up that's
yeah okay so yeah what's the what's the
key to the perfect jort to you i mean
what are you looking for because i'm not
a jordan guy they got to be they got to
be a light wash they have to you know
you have to cut the inseam right it
can't be too long because that kind of
looks weird and then the the key though
is the cut and then you have to get it
frayed you have to have the right amount
of fray right because you're a square if
you're just walking around a fresh cut
yeah yeah and the pocket has to hang
below the the the bottom line if your
pocket that's it's a little suspect yeah
if your pocket's out
we had some photos there of uh gardner
with his wife i mean you really look
like you're like you know the lead
singer for creedence clearwater or like
led zeppelin look like freaking kenny
loggins right now or something like that
yeah
you really care have you ever swam in
that jacksonville pool up there have you
ever gotten in there no i need to um it
looks like a blast you know there's been
times like on hot games i look up man
it'd be pretty good to be up there right
now yeah but um you know one day one day
maybe
all right what you got going on today
yeah so i'm here with uh snickers i got
to win their hungriest player of the
year
when this sweet chain that uh
yeah it's it's real it's for sims man
yeah be careful can i put this on for a
second yeah
this thing's insured right yeah so
that's all that is a real it's a 75 000
chain holy cow and uh you know next fall
they're going to auction it off um
which is you know a cause that i'm
related with that's you know men's
health and uh men's mental health
awareness
which often gets overlooked so i'm
excited to you know kind of be
partnering with all them yeah that's
cool man this is things the real it's
real i feel i feel like big time i'm
telling you you need to buy one yes
call me up i'll do this all day long no
problem i love snickers i eat them all
the time it's easy what's 2020 hold for
you you got nick foles on your team you
i have gotten enough of a taste of
playing you're going to want to play
what's your mindset going into this
season from the standpoint of who's
going to be the guy on the field holding
the football yeah so i got two and a
half months right now to work my tail
off to be as ready as i can be for my
team and then we'll show back up and
every day i'm gonna try to prove that
i'm the best guy for our team and i can
help us win games um you know anything
past that's not my control uh i know the
relationship between me and nick is
awesome we just had lunch with him the
other day like we both want to see each
other do well and i think when we do
that it's only going to make our team
better and uh i mean i'm look i look
forward to going into work with him
every day i have to think of all the
other guys you could have in that
setting nick foles is probably the best
he gets it he's a great teammate and if
it ends up that you're the better guy
he'll accept his role and he'll be ready
he'll be ready to play when the time
comes right that's what this situation
could have went south so many different
ways so many different times but there's
literally nobody i'd rather done it with
the nick foles he's like seriously one
of the best people i've ever been around
i've looked up to him so much like
learned so much from him and like
honestly like i'm just excited to get
back and like go to work with him yeah
cool all right we're gonna play a game
with you all right yeah we're gonna do a
little like face mashup right it's gonna
we're gonna pop it up on the screen here
and we want you to guess we got some
team names who do you think those two
people that's me and nick that's me and
nick he had that haircut at the
beginning of canvas
interesting that yeah you guys that
looks like a real person a little bit a
little bit an uglier version
oh okay yeah i don't know this one is
that man all right it's claus's face
you got half right what's that uh
is that avery jones
leonard fournette no that's not that
plays cam is that who that is that's
okay all right i don't know i couldn't
have gotten that one that bald head i
mean you're the teammate though you need
to figure that one down okay so that's
that's definitely dede somewhere in
there yeah adidas shot yep there you go
that's good yeah two out of three really
easy nailed him actually five out of six
we did make it a little easy for you
there killed it yeah new offensive
coordinator this year too and jay gruden
guy's got some head coaching experience
what do you know about him going into
this off season yeah no he's a west
coast guy i know he had uh andy dalton
at the beginning of his career did some
really great things there they went to
the playoffs three straight years
they've had some offensive offensive
success in washington yeah uh at times
so i'm excited to work with him you know
he has a system he knows that he knows
what he is and uh looking forward to
getting to work with him you're gonna
like him i know i got i played for john
jay was there with me a lot the offense
is gonna have all the answers for you i
i really think you're going to like jay
and the offense and like good luck to
you dude we like watching you the man
thank you yeah congratulations on your
success we look forward to seeing what
you and the jaguars do in 2020 and
beyond gardner minshew with the chain
you better make sure you get that
with vikings quarterback kirk cousins
right after
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports